so there there's there's a whole lot of
them 75% of medical costs stem from
behavioral and cultural issues
overeating eating too much corn syrup
smoking lack of exercise the basics the
absolute basics are causing tremendous
costs in the system and tremendous
misery among the people who have these
conditions helping people understand
their role in their own health helping
people move through a mental space where
they actually participate in making
their health better which ends up
reducing costs for their companies and
for their insurance companies is what we
need to use this technology to do and
lots of people might respond to the
ability to earn money by keeping
yourself healthy but some people might
not
some people might only respond to other
motivations like losing money or social
pressure or entertainment or being in
the know being helpful to others if you
give someone an opportunity to be
helpful to others with your condition
you see their health improved
dramatically for some personality types
and our last company tickle we had a
hundred million registered users twenty
billion questions answered we had five
PhDs on staff around the psychology of
your personality and we're you working
on something
taking that that understanding about
human motivations and creating a set of
experiences which address the seven or
eight main motivation types which apply
to seven or eight different personality
types is going to start to deepen our
ability to help people move through the
behavioral changes they need to make to
really change their health and the costs
of their health of maintaining their
health and so that's that's one of the
things that we're trying to do the the
main cost come from diabetes heart
disease obesity and asthma and allergies
those are the sort of main low-hanging
fruits that's where if you look at where
your costs are coming from that's where
they're coming from you know diabetes is
an epidemic in this country 8% of people
have diabetes at this point that's
that's a major cost center so going
after those diseases with these new
methodologies you know we've tried
disease management in the past but it's
generally been only going after one
personality type which is a nurse calls
you twice a week to berate you into
maintaining your health that works for
some people but only works for one
personality type you need to apply many
more tools to getting people to change
their behavior and you need to deploy
them in a much more cost-effective way
which having an expensive nurse call
twice a week to the whole population is
pretty expensive way to do it and and so
those are models that have failed but
there are many more models to try and
some of them are gonna work over the
next five or ten years and so that's
what made PD is is a platform for trying
out all these different ideas and then
capturing the stats about what's working
and then iterating on that and and
focusing people on the things that are
actually working evidence-based sort of
behavioral change and and that's that's
where we're going another another big
cost Center is misdiagnosis so in your
local area you're gonna have a physician
diagnosed you and they may or not may or
not may or may not have the up-to-date
information about how to diagnose
someone with these things it's estimated
that up to upwards of 40% of serious
cancer cases are misdiagnosed not that
you don't have lung cancer it's just
what type of lung cancer and the stage
you're at could be misdiagnosed which
causes you to have the wrong drugs with
the wrong program for taking those drugs
or the wrong treatments and if it's 40%
that's an incredible cost to the person
to be misdiagnosed and an incredible
cost to the system to have to treat them
for five or six months in the wrong way
before they actually get to the proper
treatment so that's another way that med
PD can help is by processing the
information more effectively and having
the most up-to-date stuff available to
everyone including your local physician
who can then tap into that knowledge
base and help help that physician
diagnose you properly more often than
not